Now, let's go back to
checking out FPS Screens.
In this screen we're doing almost
the exact same thing as in delta screen,
except instead of displaying delta,
we're displaying number of frames per
second which we can get using this
handy Gdx graphics get
frames per second column.
All right,
let's try running this game and
see how the game slash
screen life cycle works.
So when we start the app,
first the game is created, and
then we set the actor
screen to be delta screen.
So delta screen was shown and
then resized.
Now we set this up so that we can hit
space to switch between the two screens,
so let's do that now.
When we switch the screens,
delta screen had hide called.
Then FPS screen had show called,
and it was resized.
Also in that process I accidentally
clicked into and out of the screen,
so pause was called and
then resume was called on the screen.
Let's see what happens when
we close out of the game.
When we close out of the game
the active screen is first paused,
then dispose is called on the game which
automatically calls hide on the screen
that was active.